réécoutez jimmy je sais que vous sortez
un titre absolument dans l'album de
sébastien patoche sédiments là il est
sorti d'album ne s'est pas au nom c'est
en précommande vous pouvez le
précommander sur itunes
au fait et pas sûr d'être là sinon il
tenait tant j'aime pas ça je me dis
pichenette mexique
on a trop fait ou presque
c'est donc un nouveau titre bien sûr aux
écoutes et joue sur la qualité du jeu
vous parce que le mans s'appelle black
black mamba qui d'après toi donc je sais
pas d où l approche qui fait arrêter
avec ces pistes mais je vous explique
comment ça se passe oui et puis la
farine moulinette à droite même où les
détails tout le monde doit danser su
bien sûr et tué des gens du public après
s'il avait voulu line et adroit
excluez-vous moulinette à gauche salle
sarraute active salsa rotative de la
rotative
seule sa route at il une position bien
sûr du garage à vélos d'accord position
du garage à vélos d'accord quand on est
en place
épilation du cifa les i iia voilà la
halle et musique
à droite nous les nets à gauche très
salsa rotative salsa rotative position
du garage auto position des garages à
vélos épilation du site et la population
de chypre en touche à 30 ans du chat
entre sharp entrechats autres chats en
tout cas entre chats je suis refait
enfin une fois oui allez encore une fois
c'est vous attention c'est la
chorégraphie de l'été un je vous le dis
ok le gave me fait juste sur l'épilation
du cif à des melons très bien c'est non
plus 90 on y retourne 3,4 moulinet
rotative sa rotative position du canada
position avec l'épilation du style
rentre sa entrechats entretien entre sa
recrue star
entre ça vous êtes membre
merci à tous et merci merci
quartier du bosquet oui mais voilà lots
web voir le clip en qui fait un
véritable carton